- So the, the subtitle of book,
"Why The Rational
Believe The Irrational",
my point is that people that
believe conspiracy theories
are not tinfoil-hat idiots,
they're me and you, everybody.
Surveys show
everybody believes at least
one conspiracy theory,
and one reason for that, is,
by constructive conspiracicism,
a lot of 'em are true.
(chuckling)
So...
- [Dave] Right.
- It pays to be a little
constructively paranoid,
just in case.
(uptempo ambient intro music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me, today,
is the publisher of
Skeptic Magazine,
a Presidential Fellow
at Chapman University,
the host of the
Michael Shermer Show,
and author of the new book,
I've got it right
here in my hand,
"Conspiracy: Why the Rational
Believe The Irrational".
Michael Shermer, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Alright, nice
to see you, Dave.
Nice to be back.
- It's good to see
you, my friend.
Now, before I do
anything else here,
you have one of the largest
stacks of books I've ever seen,
behind you.
(Michael laughing) Is this
some kind of ploy, like,
if there's an
earthquake or somethin',
books crash on you,
clip goes viral.
It's very clever,
very clever.
- I'm killed by a conspiracy.
(both laughing)
By a plethora of
conspiracies, yes.
(Michael laughing)
- Crushed by your
own conspiracy book?
- Exactly.
- That would be odd.
It is good to see
you, my friend.
We did about 30 seconds, before
we started recording, here,
but, you have been on this
show prolly a dozen times,
in one incarnation or another,
and you also have written
400 billion books.
I...
(Michael laughing)
I did the math on that.
Now what is this, for you?
this like 16, 18 for you?
- No...
- What is it?
- 15th book, yeah.
First real book as Mr. Skeptic
was "Why People Believe
Weird Things", in 1997.
So, I average, you
know, like two a year,
somethin' like that.
Although, this
conspiracy, this is...
Last real book was 2018,
"Heavens On Earth",
so it takes me, you know,
three to four years,
really, on average,
ah, to...
- Was this a little different?
I mean, your books, obviously,
they're dense, and thoughtful,
and interesting,
and one of the things that
I always credit you for, is,
you don't pretend you
made up every idea.
You credit people accordingly,
and you call back to people,
and all sorts of things.
But, there's a lot of
research, in this book.
You had to dive
into a lot of stuff.
Does that make it
more fun, or less fun,
to write a book where
you're unpacking,
and going across
all sorts of mediums
to figure out who believes what,
and why they believe it?
- I do like to cite authors
that actually do the work,
unlike some authors,
(Dave chuckling)
whom I won't name. (chuckling)
Not you.
(chuckling) I mean, just...
There's some academics
that's not...
- Thank you, thank you.
- There's some academics that
are not especially generous
about recognizing where
they got that research.
There's actually a
huge body of literature
on conspiracies and
conspiracy theories,
why people believe
them, sociology of it,
social psych, cognitive
psych, you know?
Anthropology of
beliefs, and so on,
there's a lot in there.
So, I summarize all that,
but then try to push the
frontiers, a little bit,
with some of my own ideas.
I constructed a three-part,
tripartite, you might call it,
or three-legged-stool
of conspiricism,
proxy conspiricism,
tribal conspiricism
and constructive conspiricism.
So, there's, kind of, an
overarching theoretical model,
that holds together all
the different parts.
So, while most of the
details, of course,
are other people's research,
I've kind of put
it all together,
in an integrative whole,
under that rubric.
- Yeah, and I really
liked how you did that.
So, as you said there're sort
of three sections to the book,
a prologue that leads into it,
but then, each one, sort
of, leads into the next one.
So, I wanna get into some of
that, but broadly speaking,
one of the questions I
get the most, these days,
if I do a public event,
or if I'm doing a Q&A
online, or whatever,
is, people say to me:
"Where do you get your news?
How do you know
what to believe?"
And, I find,
it's getting increasingly
more difficult to answer that.
I, you know,
we're all going into our little
ideological echo-chambers,
I do my best to not be
in there all the time,
but it's gettin'
tough for everybody,
and as I often say, if
you're watching MSNBC,
you, basically,
live in a different world
as the Fox News person.
And I think everyone, right
now, in a modern sense,
is struggling with this.
So, the book, for that
reason, feels very relevant,
'cause I think everyone's
going through some version
of "a conspiracy
theory", to some extent.
- Yeah, well, so
here's one solution.
I actually get
newspapers, every day.
I get the New York Times,
or, see, The New York...
Oh, where's my Wall
Street Journal?
Here's my Wall Street...
Okay, I got my Wall
Street Journal.
Oh, here it is,
and the Wall Street
Journal, there we go.
So, I add 'em up and divide
by two, to get the truth.
(both laughing)
- So, in my estimation,
the Wall Street Journal
would be far more factual
than the New York Times,
which, I think, has gone
really off the deep end,
as you know.
You know, Bari Weiss,
they were so outta control,
that Bari Weiss, as a liberal,
felt she couldn't even
stay there anymore.
- Yeah.
- So, when you pick
up the New York Times,
are you basically
going, "Alright, they
screwed this one up.
Ah, that's a deflection,
this is a confusion", etc?
- Well, the Wall Street
Journal, you know,
separating the opinion
section from the news section,
you know they're both
biased, in each direction.
That we all know about,
and that's true
for any other news sources
you might wanna name.
You have to separate the...
Like, just even Fox News,
if you just take the
daytime news reporters,
they're very different
from the evening.
More like entertainers.
So, I think if you know
what you're looking at...
But, my point is, you can't
rely on any one source.
You have to go to
multiple sources,
including online sources,
and just evaluate them.
And there are sites
that evaluate the bias,
liberal or conservative bias
of different media sources.
You just have to
do that, you know?
And NPR I don't trust
so much, anymore.
AP, Associated Press, I
feel, is fairly objective,
about how they present things.
No one's completely
unbiased, of course, but...
So, multiple sources, I mean,
now there's so many, online.
Really, you just
have to, kind of,
do a little bit of
your own fact-checking.
- And if you could do...
- Yeah.
- Well, isn't that, almost,
one of the biggest
problems we have,
in this technological
adolescence that we're in,
that the average person,
that, even if they wanna stay
informed on current events,
what's goin' on in the world,
the economy,
whatever it might be,
they don't have the time.
- Right.
- To go:
"Okay, I'm gonna read The Times,
and the Wall Street Journal,
and I'll see what they're
sayin' on Fox and MSNBC",
and then they just kind
of put their hands up,
and they check out.
I think we're getting a
lot of that, actually.
- So , the subtitle of the book,
"Why the Rational
Believe the Irrational",
my point is that people that
believe conspiracy theories
are not tinfoil-hat idiots,
they're me and you, everybody.
Surveys show
everybody believes at least
one conspiracy theory,
and one reason for that, is,
by constructive conspiracicism,
a lot of 'em are true.
(chuckling)
So...
- [Dave] Right.
- It pays to be a little
constructively paranoid,
just in case, but...
So, for most, for the most part,
most people are rational
about their daily lives.
You know, they get the
kids off to school,
they hold jobs, you know,
they keep gas in the tank
and food in the fridge,
and they have a social life,
and they're just normal,
about things that they
could do something about.
Now, if you take some of
the big conspiracy theories,
like the rigged
election, say of 2020.
How would I check that,
to know what's going on?
You have to rely on sources
that have the resources
and access to check,
fact-check things like that.
I wouldn't even
know who to call,
in Ohio, or Georgia or
Arizona to ask, you know,
"What about that truck that
pulled up at 3 in the morning?"
'Cause that grainy video was
kind of suspicious, you know?
So, here we rely on people
that we should trust,
and we have, traditionally,
maybe not so much anymore.
But, for me,
whatever questions I
had were put to rest
when Attorney General
Bill Barr said:
"Well, you know, we had
the entire resources
of the Department of Justice,
and we looked into it,
and we looked here,
and we checked that,
and so on and so forth,
and didn't find anything."
It's like, "Okay, well..."
End of story", as far
as I was concerned.
Now, it's not about...
- What do you say
to the people that will go,
"Well, Bill Barr is
just part of the machine
that would produce
that sort of lie."
Because that, of
course, as you know,
you're the expert
in this, (chuckling)
I mean, conspiracies,
they jump from one, sort
of, seeming dead-end,
to a new place.
And then a new place, and a
new place and a new place.
- So what do you say?
Well, what I say, is, "Well
then, who do you trust?"
What is your source?
You know,
if you don't trust the
entire Department of Justice,
if you don't trust
the Trump-appointed
Attorney General,
or all the
Trump-appointed judges,
in the cases that he brought
before the courts, and so on,
who would you trust?
And why would you trust
somebody else, if not them?
I like quoting Christopher
Hitchens, when he says...
Which he got from somebody else,
which was that,
if you hear the Pope say
he believes in God, today,
you think, "Well, Pope's
doin' his job again, today.
That's what he's
supposed to do."
But, if you hear the
Pope say, you know,
"I'm beginning to have some
doubts about God's existence",
you think: "Ha! He might
be onto something!" Right?
So, when somebody on your team,
or somebody you trust,
says something that you
can pretty much count on,
if Bill Barr said, "Hey,
I found some suspicion",
well, of course he's a Trump
appointee, a Republican,
maybe we need another source.
But, if he says, if he would
be motivated to find fraud,
and he didn't,
then, to me,
that ups the probability there
was no fraud in the election.
That's just, kind of,
how to think about that
kind of conspiracy theory.
- Right. So, since we're
talking about the election,
and I do think so much of
what we now talk about,
related to fake news,
and this confusion that has
to do with the election,
what would you say
about the four years
that Trump was president,
when, basically,
half of the media,
or all of the mainstream
media, in essence,
was saying either he
was a Russian plant,
or that that election was
illegitimate, or stolen,
and then the second those
people were on the other side,
now we have Biden as president,
they say you can't
question anything,
and you're gonna be booted
off Twitter and YouTube,
and everywhere else, if you do.
- That's pretty predictable,
everybody does that.
If you go back in time, decades,
pretty much every losing side
in a presidential election,
or even congressional
races and senatorial races,
the losing side thinks the
other side did something.
There was some shenanigans,
there was some...
And then, they usually drop
it, after a few months,
and focus on the next
election, or whatever.
So what's unusual, this
time, is that, you know,
Trump continues with
the conspiracy theory.
But that's...
Let's not blame Republicans,
'cause Democrats do this, also.
It's pretty common,
because, again,
you know, it's so complex,
there's so many moving parts
in a national election,
no-one has access to
all the information.
So, you know, there's always
gonna be some anomalies,
you know, and then people go
anomaly-hunting as we call it,
and then you can always
find 'em, no matter what.
Again, that blurry
video of the truck,
that pulled up at three,
what is that? You know?
"Okay, he had a box..."
Okay, you know, there's
always something like that.
So we have to, part of the
problem is the lack of trust.
We've always had
trust in our systems,
that, for the most part,
they work pretty well.
And yeah, so that's...
But again, like with
Trump, you know,
I've been pretty
critical of Trump,
particularly since, you
know, in that last year,
but pretty much
everything else he did
was pretty standard
Republican stuff, you know?
Always lowering taxes, he's
helping rich people get richer,
he's tightening up the borders,
foreign policy, and so on.
It's like, that's his job,
like the Pope, that's his job.
That's what he's supposed to do.
(chuckling) You know?
So it's only, like, when
George H.W. Bush, you know,
"Read my lips, no new
taxes", then he raised taxes.
Like, what?
(Dave chuckling)
You're a Republican, you're
not supposed to do that, right?
So, we have expectations,
and Trump, you know,
deregulation of the economy,
that was pretty standard
Republican stuff.
And Biden's doing what
Democrats do, right?
I mean, so, you know,
it's not fair to criticize
either one as being extremists
when most of the
policies they're doin'
is pretty standard.
- What do you think,
since you mentioned trust,
what do you think we can do?
Or, not we, I suppose,
whatever mainstream
institutions that still exist,
at this point,
and it's hard to tell to what
degree they exist, anywhere,
who's watching these things,
how much influence they have,
how could they gain back trust?
I think, in most cases,
if you were to take, say
the New York Times or CNN,
I don't think there's
a way back, now.
I think they've gone so
all-in on so much confusion,
and been so exposed
as partisan players,
that I don't know that they
can come back from that,
and maybe they shouldn't.
- I dunno.
Well, okay, so...
But, but I'd say Fox News
has the same problem.
You know, they've, kind of,
dialed into a business
model of, you know,
ramping up the
extremism on their side.
I don't know.
You know, you mentioned,
Russian-gate, and
all that stuff,
all those accusations
against Trump, you know,
most of which did not pan out.
Those were conspiracy
theories, you know?
We think this happened,
and it turned out, the
Mueller report, and so on.
Ah, well, okay,
that was, kind of,
a nothin'-burger.
That doesn't help,
right? (chuckling)
- Right, right.
- So that if you
actually get something,
it's like, "Yeah, well you
cried wolf so many times..."
So that's not a problem.
So, the larger
problem, I see it,
is an erosion of trust,
across the board.
Scientists used to be trusted,
the CDC used to be trusted,
teachers, professors,
the academy used to be,
you know, high in
trust, not anymore.
And so, my last chapter,
"How to Rebuild Trust",
you know, that's a hard problem.
But, I sign on
with Jonathan Rauch's "The
Constitution of Knowledge",
I think you had
Jonathan on your show?
- We've talked,
briefly, once, yeah.
- Okay. Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But this, kind
of, commitment to,
like, in journalism,
fact-checking
and in science, peer-review,
in the judicial
system, you know,
a fair, confrontational
trial between two attorneys,
you know, to get to the truth,
and jury of your
peers, and so on...
So, there's, you know,
here's, kind of, the
conservative argument,
for maintaining institutions
that have been around
for decades or centuries,
and the reason we keep
them, is 'cause they work.
We've been tweaking
them for centuries,
the legal system,
the criminal justice system,
journalism, really,
maybe a century, now,
they've had, you know,
standards, actual standards,
Fact-checking, and editors,
and things like that.
You know, that, we rely on that,
and, we just have to
keep pushing back,
that it's just not cool
to make assertions without
any evidence at all.
- Yeah, you know,
it's interesting,
I'm guessing, I think
you either read...
Well, you certainly read it,
or maybe wrote a
review of it, even,
in Jordan Peterson's last
book, in "12 More Rules",
I think the first of the
new set of rules, you know,
is, in essence you
gotta be careful,
when you're burning
down institutions,
because you don't know what
will come, on the other side.
And, I think,
that's kind of, where
we're at, right now.
We don't trust the
old institutions,
but we don't know exactly
what the new institutions are.
- Yeah, exactly.
Well that's, that's classic
Burkean Conservativism,
Edmund Burke defended
the US Revolution,
sorry, the, the
Revolutionary War,
but not the French Revolution.
And he was right, you know,
because they tore down
everything, "Let's
just start over",
all the way down to a new
calendar system, you know,
and new titles, and
new days of the...
Everything's gonna be different.
And, that didn't pan
out so well, so...
And again, you know,
certain institutions
have been around,
that have been around
for a long time,
and they've been tweaked,
here and and there,
to be more efficient, and
fair and just, and so on.
We should keep the...
We should not throw them,
overthrow them, too easily.
And...
- So you mentioned...
You mentioned science, before,
and as a man of science,
and a man who likes facts,
having been through
two years of COVID,
and you are in California,
which I fled, because of COVID,
and lockdowns, and masks,
and injections, you know,
mandated injections,
all of these things
that I felt had nothing
to do with science,
and I think in...
Or, virtually nothing
to do with science,
or a abuse of
science, let's say.
How shaky do you think the
scientific world is, right now?
I mean, Fauci, just in
the last couple days,
saying, "Oh, I was
never for lockdowns",
and then it's, like,
we're playin' videos on the show
where he's callin'
for lockdowns.
- Yeah.
- A year ago.
And remember when he said,
"When you criticize
me, I am the science,
you're criticizing science."
- Yeah.
Yeah, so that's...
It's been a problem for the
reputation of science, I guess,
because the CDC says one thing,
and then changes it's mind,
or Fauci says, you know,
"No masks", then
"Masks", then "No masks".
But, in a way...
Okay, let's just step aside
from particular individuals,
like Fauci, and just
say, in general,
if you don't know
what's goin' on,
and we didn't, you know?
It was January, 2020,
then March is when we
were, kind of, realizing,
"Okay, there's something big
happening, here, what is it?"
And, it took a long time,
to figure out what's
the right thing to do.
There's so much uncertainty,
and so much unpredictability
in complex systems,
like the human body,
if, you know...
Why do some people
get the virus,
who double-vaxxed, boosted,
they lead clean, healthy lives,
you know, they're
isolated, masked,
and they get it, anyway?
And, I know people that didn't
do anything. (chuckling)
They didn't change
their life, at all.
Never wore a mask, never got...
And they get it,
nothin' happens, right?
(chuckling)
So it's like, okay...
'Cause there's
variation, you know,
the body's a complex system,
and people respond
differently, and so it's...
These are, on average,
recommendations,
and I try to be sympathetic,
by putting myself in somebody...
If I was a public policy person,
if I was the head of
a health institute,
or I was the mayor of
the city, of LA, say,
or governor of California,
and they stick a
microphone in your face,
they go, "Okay, what do we do?"
So, here you have kind of a
type one/type two error problem,
signal detection problem.
If I say "Business as usual",
and it turns out it's
like Ebola or AIDS,
you remember AIDS was
a 100% fatal, at first.
What if it turns out
like that, you know?
And I really screwed
up, (chuckling)
and it's on me.
So, they're more likely
to err on the other side.
Like, let's err on the side
of making a type one error,
assume it's gonna be
terrible, and if it isn't,
well, we got lucky.
Of course, they're not
calculating into the equation
the effects of
lockdown, isolation,
masks, school closures,
economic effects, and so on.
Which, I think,
we're years away from knowing
what the full effects
of that will be.
So far it looks like it
has damaged our economy,
and other things.
School kids are behind,
and social attitudes
of our youngsters,
and how they interact
with each other.
You know, there's some
studies coming out, now,
showing, you know, these kids,
just coming into college now...
I have freshmen,
myself, you know,
they're very different than
they were a few years ago.
It's hard to say
what the cause is,
but social isolation
during COVID might be one.
Anyway, those are
the (indistinct)...
- Wait, I'm curious, though.
How are you seeing
that manifested in
your students, now,
from say, five years ago?
- Super-quiet.
Very, very reticent
to say anything.
There may be some...
- Wow...
- There may be some
cancel-culture effects, there.
You know people...
'Cause I bring up abortion,
like we just did an issue
on abortion, so, you know,
"Pro-life, pro-choice, alright,
kids, let's talk about it",
and they're, you know,
they're like, "Uh, ey, er..."
(chuckling)
- [Dave] Wow...
- They're afraid to say
anything, it's like,
"How can you not
have an opinion,
on abortion?"
- And you're at Chapman,
which is a great
defender of free speech.
- Yes, yes.
- I mean,
one of the few
universities that is.
- Yeah, so here,
this is reflecting
more of a bottom-up kind
of cultural shift, I think.
Maybe they're just
shy, I don't know.
But, you know, yesterday,
one of my student Ted talks
was on attractiveness,
"lookism".
You know, why is it
that good-looking people
get more benefits than
others? (chuckling)
Like, "Alright, you gotta have
an opinion on this, right?
Here's Brad Pitt,
that's so unfair!
What are you gonna
do about Brad Pitt?"
You know, and they're look
like looking around like,
"Oh, I don't wanna
say anything."
I'm like, "Oh, come on, man..."
So, it could be some of that.
you know, we do know there's
a uptick in depression,
and cutting, suicidal ideation,
particularly amongst girls.
You know, is it social media?
Is it Facebook?
Is it social isolation
during COVID?
You know, there's
different factors,
we don't know yet,
but something...
There are some effects to that.
- I'm curious, how
much of this, say,
related to COVID, was people
that, maybe, weren't qualified,
or, in some ways,
were overqualified
to give information,
giving information?
So, an example I would use,
is right when the
pandemic happened,
I had a bunch of experts on,
people that are
fairly well-known,
and they were talking
about how to wash your bags
when you leave
the grocery store,
and perfectly, you know,
put your mask on this way,
and talking about
social distancing,
a phrase that no one had
really uttered, before.
And all of these strange things,
and lockdowns,
which really had never
been done before, at scale,
and were based on, basically,
some wonky paper that
never meant anything,
but everyone just started
saying the same thing.
Then, when we find
out it doesn't work,
everyone just looks
at the expert class,
and goes...
And I'm not talking about
the Faucis, or even the CDCs,
I'm just talking about
the general people,
who are the taste-makers,
everyone just looks
at them, and is like,
"You guys just screwed
us all, terribly."
- (chuckling) That's right.
Right, so whenever
there's uncertainty,
about the cause of something,
say autism,
you know, one reason vaccines
got associated with autism
is 'cause we don't know
the cause of autism.
We still don't.
There's probably
multiple causes,
some genetic
predispositions, who knows?
You know, in-the-womb
chemistry, I don't know.
You know, we don't know.
But so, anything that's
even loosely associated,
then gets affiliated
as a causal vector.
And, I think we see a lot of
that in pandemics, like this,
where you just don't know.
Remember, when AIDS first
came online, I mean,
there was like panic,
"Oh, you shouldn't go
in the swimming pool."
I remember when Greg Louganis
cut his head on
the diving board,
Barbara Walters
was doing this private
one-on-one interview with him,
and he talked about this,
She said, "Oh my god, Greg,
you went in the pool?"
(chuckling)
- [Dave] Right, right.
- 'Cause, at the time,
it was like, "Oh, it could
spread through water, the air,
don't get on a bus
with an AIDS patient."
You know? "It's a gay
disease", all this crazy stuff.
There was conspiracy theories
about it, the Black community,
that the CIA was up to
something, with AIDS,
and, you know...
But these are not
completely crazy.
This is under my rubric of
constructive conspiracism.
- [Dave] Yeah, yeah.
- You know, because the
Tuskegee experiments,
where they, you know,
withheld treatments to African
Americans with syphilis,
and other shenanigans that
the CIA and the FBI have done,
to infiltrate Black
activist groups,
to blackmail Martin Luther
King Jr. and threaten,
if he doesn't kill himself,
they're gonna expose...
They made sex tapes of him,
in hotel rooms, with
women, and said,
"We're gonna play
these, publicly,
if you don't kill
your..." (chuckling)
This is our
government, did this.
So, it's not completely
crazy for people who...
"You know, I don't
trust the government."
(chuckling) It's like,
"Yeah, okay, I understand."
(laughing)
- So, in essence, by
the end of reading this,
most people would be a little
more libertarian, perhaps?
- Well...
- 'Cause you do go into
several other examples...
- Yes.
- Of that, about how governments
have been doin' this.
- Oh yes, yes, right,
MK Ultra, CIA dosing
US citizens with LSD,
just to see what would happen.
They actually set
up, in brothels,
you know, they had
these johns come in,
and they would
dose 'em with LSD,
and then watch, film them
having sex with prostitutes,
"Let's see what
happens, here", right?
It was all under this,
kinda, larger plan,
that, you know, remember
the missile gap?
Well, this was the,
the mind-control gap.
You know, the Chinese,
and the Russians,
and the North Koreans are ahead
of us on mind-control drugs,
so we gotta do
experiments, on this.
So, again, no
congressional approval.
People didn't know about it.
President didn't
even know about it.
You know, this is just,
like, rogue factions,
in the security
state, doing this.
So when people talk
about the, "Deep State",
there's people behind
the scenes doing things,
well, historically, that
has happened, right?
That's just MK Ultra,
that's just one.
This, you know, this
counterintelligence program,
this COINTELPRO, was
another, you know?
Let's plant some people in
these social justice groups,
like the Black Panthers, AIM,
the American Indian Movement,
feminist groups, and so on,
just to make 'em look bad,
or, essentially, create
like a false flag operation?
You know, let's send
in one of our guys,
they'll do something
really stupid,
and then, then this
will get on the show,
covered in the media, and
then they'll look bad.
I mean, this is like, "What?
Our our government does this?"
(chuckling) Yeah.
- Do do you think it's odd,
that these things are
not discussed more?
I mean, you go into all of
these things in the book,
but, you know,
fringe internet people
talk about these things.
Guys that run Skeptic Magazine
talk about these things,
but you know,
in a time where we've watched
the institutions fail,
people would be wise to
be a bit more skeptical
about the information
they're being fed.
- Yeah, you should be.
Right, so, I think of it as
a signal detection problem,
that is the signals you're
getting in, versus the noise.
You know, is it a real
pattern, or is it not?
That is, the pattern you
think is a conspiracy theory,
that represents a
real conspiracy, is
that true, or not?
And so, my argument
is that, well,
it's probably better to err
on the side of
being trigger-happy,
like assume it's
real when it's not,
'cause that's a less
costly mistake to make
than miss the real conspiracy.
Somebody in your company is
conspiring to hold you down,
or some other company is
conspiring against your company,
or, you know, whatever, just...
Governments do these
things, all the time.
And just look at, you know,
what the CIA did in...
You know, rigged election,
well, the CIA used to
try to rig elections
in South American countries
to favor fascist dictators
over communist dictators,
'cause they were friendlier to
American business interests,
in those countries.
And, you know, again, this
was all under the radar.
No-one knew about it until,
you know, decades later,
when it was exposed.
And so, that's that
constructive conspiracism.
You should be...
- It's almost
as if things might
be going on now
that we don't know
exactly what's happening.
- I have no doubt this
is the case, right?
And we won't know
for another 20 years,
somebody does a Freedom of
Information Act, you know,
FOIA request, and finds
out, "Oh my God, in 2022,
you know what the CDC,
or whoever, was up to?"
"Oh, okay."
(chuckling) "No, I
didn't know that."
- Where do you
think social media,
or how do you think
social media plays a part,
in all of this?
You know, one of the things,
just in terms of the way
the internet's structured,
that I always think about, is,
I remember the internet
when it started,
or, you know,
started on basic AOL,
or Prodigy, or something,
you'd go to a website,
you'd get to the bottom of
the page, and that was it.
Meaning, you could scroll
for a certain period of time,
then it would stop.
Then we got infinite scroll.
So, more and more
and more kept coming.
If you're on Twitter, you can
go more, and more and more.
That rabbit-hole
is endless, now,
and I think a lot
of that, probably,
also feeds a certain
part of the brain
that would lead people
to some of these ideas.
- Yeah, it does.
I mean the history
of conspiracism,
there's always been
conspiracy theories,
nothing new there,
but, but the spread
of them in real-time,
and the depth that
people could go.
I talk about it in the book,
of the JFK conspiracy theorists,
you know, back in
the '60s, '70s,
they're just meeting in
little hotel conference-rooms,
with two dozen people,
and they had their little
mimeographed newsletters
that they'd mail out,
(chuckling) you know?
And so, not very many people,
you know, knew about this,
or were into it.
Now you can reach, you
know, millions of people,
instantly, in real-time,
and so the spread is more rapid.
The, you know, kind of,
going down the rabbit-hole,
the siloing off of people
into these communities,
that it's hard to penetrate,
you know, that's
the harder part.
- Is it, do you think,
also easier to debunk
some of these things,
because of the speed
of information?
Just as fast as it can spread,
it can also be debunked
that much more quickly?
- Yeah, to me, that's
the only solution,
is that, because I'm not
in favor of censorship,
or kicking people
off of social media
'cause they said
the wrong thing.
This doesn't help,
for two reasons,
one, you might be wrong,
and that guy that you just
kicked off, he might be right.
No one's omniscient,
how do you know?
You know, John Stewart
Mill, you know, it's like,
if he who knows only
his own position
doesn't even know that...
So, it's good to listen
to these other people,
and then second, if
you kick somebody off,
cancel-culture, and so on,
then outsiders
observing this will go,
"Oh, I wonder if that guy
has something to say?"
Because they're making such
a big deal about it, right?
Banned in Boston: "Ooh, I
wanna read those banned books."
- Right.
(Michael chuckling)
- And so, you know,
when someone like Joe
Rogan has on Robert Malone,
to talk about vaccines
and cardio issues,
you know, everybody made
a big stink about that.
It's like, well, first of all,
Joe's not 60 Minutes, where
he has to have, you know,
guests on each side, or
whatever, it's not what he does.
You know that, going in.
But if you make a
big deal about it,
now everyone wants to know,
"Well, who is this
Robert Malone guy,
and what is his argument?"
Because, no-one
seems to debunk it,
they just say, "Oh, it
was bad he had him on."
Well, okay, what is the problem?
Somebody should say,
"Here's the argument,
and here's the response."
- And, what's so
interesting about that, is,
if you remember,
so he has Dr. Malone,
on who had, I think,
if I'm not mistaken,
more patents on mRNA
technology than anybody.
I mean, it's not like
this guy's a kook, right?
- Right.
- So he has him on,
the media goes crazy about it,
because he's talking
about Ivermectin,
and all of these things,
and then, you remember what
happened, about four days later,
where, suddenly,
we had a week of Joe
Rogan saying the N word,
and should Joe Rogan be
de-platformed off Spotify,
and everywhere else?
And that, I think, led
people to believe...
You know,
I don't even know that this
is a conspiracy theory,
but that there was some
sort of coordinated attack
by the corporate press on Rogan.
Like, he was becoming
too influential,
so it behooved CNN
to push these, "Oh, Joe
Rogan's a racist" stories,
because he's moving
in on their territory.
I don't know if
that's a conspiracy,
I mean, I don't have the
documents from Zucker at CNN,
(Michael chuckling)
but it feels like something
that's, kind of, there.
- I suspect that's not
a top-down conspiracy,
like we think of a
conspiracy theory,
of, you know, the Illuminati,
or somebody power...
Cigarette-smoking people
behind closed doors,
who're calling the shots.
And the reason I'm skeptical
of most of those theories
is because the world
is too complex,
there's too much randomness,
there's too much chaos
from the bottom up,
and no one can control it.
No one's in control.
This is part of my theory,
is that it's one thing
to be a little afraid,
or anxious about there's
some cabal going on,
of 12 people called the
Illuminati, running the world,
and doing a crappy job of it.
(both chuckling)
But, it's quite
another to think,
"Actually, nobody's in control."
Right there, no one can explain
the economy, why wars...
I mean, I don't think
Putin even knows
if he's gonna use
tactical nukes or not,
let alone Biden or the
Defense Department, or...
I don't think anybody knows.
It's just impossible to know.
So, I think...
- Do you view that as...
Is that scary, or
more comforting,
if nobody's in control?
- I like it, 'cause
I'm, kinda, libertarian,
in my personal attitudes,
and it's okay with me.
But people that
prefer a structured,
hierarchical worldview,
that's predictable, they're not.
They tend to be
more conspiratorial,
in their thinking.
A little more paranoid,
a little more suspicious
that there's things going on.
And again, things do go
on, so how do you know?
Well, my little
test is, you know,
the more people that have to
be involved in the conspiracy,
the less likely
the theory is true.
The more components that
have to come together,
just at the right time
and the right place,
again, it's probably not likely,
if a lot of things have
to happen, because,
again, chance, chaos,
contingency,
accidents, you know?
People just don't do what
they're supposed to do.
You know, I remember that,
when my first book came out,
I went on G. Gordon Liddy's
radio show, in Washington DC,
"Why People Believe
Weird Things", so...
I discussed conspiracies
a little bit in there,
and he asked me
about it, and I said,
"Well, you're the expert,
(chuckling) you're
Mr. Watergate."
And he says,
"Well, actually, most
conspiracies are a
bunch of baloney,
conspiracy theories are,
because people can't
keep their mouths shut,
and most people
are incompetent."
And, you know, so this is
like 9/11 truth, you know,
the Bush administration
was in on 9/11,
let it happen on
purpose, (indistinct),
or made it happen, on
purpose (indistinct).
Well, in fact,
negative evidence,
WikiLeaks, you know, millions
of classified documents,
not one, not one
document about 9/11,
or "We know they're coming",
or "We're gonna let it happen",
or, you know,
planting explosive.
Nothing, right?
So, that tells me, if
it was an inside job,
and these were
classified documents,
we would predict that there
should be some leakage, there.
There isn't.
Because, most conspiracies, we
do find out about 'em, right?
Lincoln was assassinated
by conspiracy.
We knew within hours who did it.
Same thing with Kennedy,
I mean, Oswald was
discovered within an hour,
they had him, at that theater.
And so, we find out
about these things,
but not one person wants
to go on record about,
you know, the fake moon-landing,
or 9/11 is an inside job, or...
Not one.
So, that's very
probably not true.
- What would you say
about something like the
Hunter Biden laptop story?
Where, you know, New York Post,
which is generally thought of
as a reputable
news organization,
they say "This is true."
They, you know, they
have their sources, etc.
Big tech Twitter,
particularly, comes in,
you can't share these stories,
you can't even share them
through your own
private messaging,
your own direct messaging
on our platform.
Then other platforms
start doing it, as well.
Of course, it all
turns out to be legit,
and there's a lot of pretty,
pretty bad stuff, on there,
some nasty stuff, on there.
I think a lot of people
see that as a
coordinated conspiracy,
that, in essence,
that thing was going to
be damaging to Joe Biden,
they wanted Joe Biden
to be president,
they wanted to be rid of Trump,
we accept that big tech
can just get in, on this.
Like, does that...
Is that a conspiracy,
or is that 'cause he...
- Yeah, interesting.
- Yeah.
- That's an interesting
example, 'cause, here,
it would be a conspiracy
in the traditional sense,
if, say, the news networks
called each other,
and said, you know, "I'm
not gonna run this story.
Are you gonna run the story?"
"I won't run it if
you won't run it."
If that was shown,
that would be a more traditional
definition of a conspiracy.
More likely, is, it's more
of, kind of, a cultural shift,
or trend.
We're all liberals, we
wanna protect our guy,
and so, we're just
gonna bury the story.
I'm gonna do it,
you're gonna do it.
It's, kind of, common knowledge.
I don't have to call you up,
you just know that, you know,
we're gonna, kinda,
work together,
to support our guy, or
criticize the other guy,
that's more normal.
That happens, I think, a lot,
without the concerted, top-down,
you know, private phone-calls,
kind of, messaging, to
coordinate the effort.
That would be my
suspicion, for that one.
- You know, when, when Alex
Jones was banned, after...
Was he banned after Sandy Hook,
or was he banned
after (indistinct)?
- Or, yeah, no,
it, it was...
Yeah, it was after
Sandy Hook, for sure.
- Yeah, well, I know it
was after Sandy Hook,
I don't remember if that was,
like, the full impetus for it,
but, whenever, he got
banned by everybody,
within a day or so.
I actually had Thiel, Peter
Thiel on my show, the next day,
and I asked him privately, he
has since said it publicly,
I said, "Well, what do
you think happened, here?
You know, did they
all coordinate?"
And he said, I think
you'll appreciate this.
He said, actually,
what he thought was,
well, you know, once
one of them did it,
once Twitter, I think
Twitter did it first,
then it was just the
signal to everybody else,
just go ahead and do it.
Like now...
- Right, right.
with the error, we took the hit,
we did it,
so, it's not a coordinated
phone-call conspiracy
that you're talking about,
but it is, it's
some other level,
related to fear
and manipulation,
and how we all
operate, I suppose.
- It's...
Here's an analogy,
an athlete gets
busted for doping,
or some, you know,
horrible thing they did,
and Nike drops 'em,
and then, within an hour,
everybody else drops them.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Now, I don't think Nike called
any of the other companies,
said "You gotta drop the guy."
They all look around and go,
"Well we better go, you know,
what everybody, the
big guy's doin',
and show our support for a
criticism of this athlete",
or whatever it is.
- What...
So, part two of the way
you lay out the book
is how to determine which
conspiracies are real.
So we're, sort of, bouncing
around a lot of that,
in the political sense.
What about in just...
And, let's get away from
politics for a second,
just every other sense,
there's aliens, and Area 51,
and all the other
stuff that we're all...
How do you figure
out what's real?
You know, somebody
visited you at night,
and they poked,
they're always pronging people,
and all that stuff.
(Michael chuckling)
- Yeah.
Right, so some of the
criteria I mentioned already,
you know, how many people
have to be involved,
how many elements
have to come together,
at just the right moment.
How typical...
How conspiracies really unfold,
I went into detail,
in that chapter on what
triggered the First World War,
which was a group of
Serbian nationalists,
called the Black Hand,
who conspired to
assassinate Franz Ferdinand,
the heir-apparent of the
Austria-Hungarian Empire,
who was leaning on Serbia
to control them, and so on.
So, this was a cabal, for sure.
They met in secret,
they plotted for months,
you know,
each of the seven guys had
to go to a certain house,
and give the code-word, and
then they get the weapon,
a pistol or a
hand-grenade, and so on.
And, and you know,
one guy didn't,
he went to the wrong house,
another guy chickened out,
somebody else, you
know, got the weapon,
but went to the wrong
place on the parade-route,
where he was supposed to stand.
And then, finally,
some guy actually was able to
pull the pin on the grenade,
and throw it, but it
bounced off the archduke's,
the back of his car,
rolled under the car behind
him and blew up there,
and so these people
got hurt, "Oh no!"
And then, the car zooms off,
and he goes off to his little
meeting, gives a speech,
says "Thanks a lot, I
come here to to Sarajevo,
and you guys throw bombs at me."
And then he leaves,
and then said,
"Hey, we better go
back to the hospital,
and check on our comrade."
So the driver goes back
down the same road,
that they were at,
and he turns right,
on the Appel Quay,
the main drag, there,
where the last conspirator,
this Gavrilo Princip,
was sitting there, despondent,
eating a sandwich
from this deli,
and he's got his pistol in
his pocket, and he's like,
"Well that was a big
fuck-up, nothing happened."
And then, all of a sudden,
here comes the car,
and the car makes a wrong turn,
and there was no reverse in it,
so, the driver puts it neutral,
and just backs up at,
like, one mile-an-hour,
right in front of
this Gavrilo Princip,
He's like, "Oh my
God!" Bam, dead.
That's how these things
normally go, right?
You know, I mean, Nixon,
with the, you know,
the G-men, and the FBI,
couldn't even break into the
Democratic hotel, at Watergate.
(Dave chuckling)
Right?
- [Dave] Right.
- I mean, again, if
those guys can't do it...
And, by my example, that's
how things usually go.
The more complex it has to be,
the less likely
the theory is true.
9/11 truth? Impossible.
I mean, first of all,
you'd have to have hundreds
of people involved,
to break through the drywall
of the World Trade
Center building rooms
to get into the
structural beams,
and wrap 'em in these
explosive devices,
you know, which is how
it's done, you know?
The abandoned buildings
that they demolish,
they have to break 'em apart,
and put the explosive
devices in there.
Nobody saw that, how did...
Yeah, "Oh, they operated
under the pretense
of being elevator repairers."
Like, I mean, now you're
just hand-waving, you know,
it's just crazy.
And not one person wants
to go on 60 Minutes,
and say, "I knew somebody,
I was dating this guy,
and he told me all about
the 9/11, oh my God,
I have a book out..."
Nobody, you know,
has come forth.
Very, very unlikely,
as opposed to 19 members of
Al-Qaeda with box-cutters.
See, so, so there's kind
of a disparate effect,
between cause and effect.
You know, the bigger the effect,
the bigger the
cause, to match it,
or else, we...
You know, just
doesn't feel right.
So you get, you know,
JFK killed by who?
This Lee Harvey
Oswald, the lone nut?
That doesn't feel right.
So you add KGB, and the FBI,
and the Russians and the
Cubans and the Mafia,
and now it feels better.
Princess Diana, cause of death?
Drunk driving,
speeding, no seatbelt.
Tens of thousands of people
die like that, every year,
but princesses are not supposed
to die like that, right?
So, it's gotta be the
MI6, and the royal family,
and Prince Charles and
ugh, whoever, you know,
is supposed to be in on this,
and I think that there's
an effect like that.
Like, "There's no way Al-Qaeda
could have done that."
That's the actually the
only way that could happen.
Just somebody in the nooks and
crannies of a free society,
that no one notices,
that's how you get
away with stuff.
- You know, it's funny
'cause you can also see,
how, through pop culture,
some of this stuff leaks in.
I mean, obviously, the movie
JFK was absolutely massive.
And, I'm sure you...
- Massive.
- Well, like,
I've no doubt that you don't
agree with the conclusions
that Oliver Stone was
putting forth, in the movie.
But, even, I was
watching The Crown,
on Netflix, a year or so ago,
and, in the last season,
where there's a lot
about Princess Di,
you know, in essence,
you're watching the thing,
and you're, kinda, like,
"Yeah, it seems like
they wanted to kill her."
(Michael chuckling)
And, you know, then
she ends up dead, so...
- Yeah.
- It just, sort of,
just sits there,
and you could ruminate
about all of these things.
- Of course that's
hindsight bias.
You know, tons of
people hated Obama,
but he wasn't assassinated,
so end of story,
no one's talking about what
happened to those people,
why didn't they kill him?
(chuckling)
Well, it's hard to kill
a president, right?
(chuckling)
It's hard to pull that off.
- Plenty of people
would've been glad to
take out Donald Trump.
You know, Michael,
I'm reminded of a
couple years ago,
we've told this story
once or twice, publicly,
but, we were at, I
think, Arizona State.
- Oh right.
- University,
if I'm not mistaken, we were
doin' a talk on free speech,
and I, at the top of the
show, I say to the audience,
I don't know, a couple
hundred kids, there,
I say, you know, "How many
Democrats, how many Republicans,
how many libertarians?"
And then I said,
"How many Nazis?"
Just to get a laugh.
And one person stood
up, in the back,
and said that they were a Nazi.
And I think you said,
"Hey", you know,
"If you just wait till the end,
we'll take your question first,
then that'll be interesting,
and let's see what happens."
So, we end our talk,
and then we take the
question from the Nazi,
and the Nazi had all
these conspiracy theories,
about the Holocaust,
and the gas chambers,
and all of this stuff.
I should also mention,
it turned out that the
Holocaust-denier was also trans,
which is just, sort of, an
interesting detail, I suppose.
But, what you did, I thought,
was really beautiful,
because you just
flat-out explained
why the conspiracy theory
was not a conspiracy at all.
- Right, and to me,
that's the way to handle
these kinds of things.
I mean, if you tell 'em
to shut up, or sit down,
or silence them,
or kick 'em out,
then onlookers are gonna go,
"Well what's the
story with that?
What's the problem
with that argument?"
So you gotta, at some point,
you gotta address the argument,
which I did in my book, on that.
- And you'd been to the
concentration camps, right?
- Yes.
- You'd been to Poland,
where you... Can you explain
a little bit about that?
Just the sort of interesting...
- Oh well, so, yeah, Holocaust
denial, or revisionism,
or whatever you wanna call it,
they're not claiming that no
Jews were were killed or died,
they're just downgrading,
from 6 million to about
a million, maybe 500,000.
So, it's a clever strategy,
'cause no matter what
photos you show, like,
"Here's bodies
stacked like cordwood,
at this concentration-camp,
how do you explain that?"
"Oh, that's part
of the half-million
I'm willing to admit died,
of disease and starvation,
and overwork, and so on."
"Oh, okay. And you know, what
about these gas-chambers?"
"Oh, those were used
for delousing clothing."
"Okay, well,
what's the difference
between a delousing chamber
and a homicidal gas chamber?"
There is a difference,
but you have to know
something about that, right?
So, it does require
some knowledge.
Like, could you explain how,
why the flat-earthers are wrong?
Could you explain why
creationists are wrong?
Holocaust are wrong,
are wrong, whatever.
So, you have to...
So that's, kind of,
what we specialize in,
it's skeptic, you know?
What are the best arguments
the 9/11 truthers actually
have, and what's your response?
How do controlled-demolition
buildings fall?
Do they fall from the top
down, or the bottom up?
It's the bottom up,
the opposite of what
we saw in the videos.
Okay, so, but you have
to know that, kind of,
little bit of detail,
arcane knowledge.
And so, I did that
with the Holocaust,
and, you know, it's
harder to prove intention,
but there's enough memos,
from Hitler, Himmler,
Goebbels and so on,
that indicate that
they, after 1941,
they intended to
exterminate European Jewry.
It was not just an accidental
by-product of the war.
And then, finally, that
the gas-chambers were used,
well, there's six death-camps.
Here's another trick that
the revisionists use,
right after war, they said
there were 21 death camps,
now they say there's only six.
The ever-diminishing
death-camps,
pretty soon it will be zero.
No, this is how history
normally works, right?
You have the kind of real-time
reporting by journalists,
and then the first round of
books after an event, or a war,
then the second
round, and so on,
that's when you get
more information,
you change your mind, right?
So, okay, it's six.
And you can go there,
and you can measure the Zyklon
blue staining on the bricks,
at Majdanek, for
example, and see,
well, that was the chamber
where they killed people,
it's very different
from the ones where
they delouse clothing.
And you just, kind of,
go through all that.
Now, when somebody,
at this point, says,
"I still think the Jews, you
know, are up to no good",
like, alright, so now you
wanna talk about the Jews,
and not the Holocaust, right?
So, you have to
kind of bore down,
to see what the
deeper motive is.
You know, like, like
with Qanon, or Pizzagate,
you know,
there's no possible way somebody
could really believe that,
except that one
guy, Edgar Welch,
who went there with a gun,
to that Comet Ping Pong.
So, when most people
say they believe that,
they mean something else.
Like, "I don't like Democrats",
"I don't trust that Hillary",
you know, "The
Clintons are evil."
I just don't...
You know, such that if I
took you to the pizza place,
and showed you there's
no pedophile ring,
here's not even a basement.
It's not like you're gonna go,
"In that case I'll
vote for Hillary."
(Dave chuckling)
- Right.
- You were never
gonna vote for Hillary, so...
- Right, and I remember,
after that incident
at Arizona State,
when we were all breakin' up,
I think you continued
to talk to the woman,
and, in essence,
I asked you after,
"Well, do you think you
convinced her of anything?"
And you, basically, were like,
"No, that's, that's not
really how it works",
because the deprogramming,
no matter how much you
offer, in some ways,
is almost impossible to get to.
That's right.
- Which, I think,
is sort of what part three
of the book is about.
- That's right.
Yeah, all I was gonna do
is plant a seed of doubt.
Like, "How did
you get that idea?
Where did it come from?
What was the source?
What's the quality
of the evidence?
How do you know that's true,
versus some other hypothesis?
What it would take to change
your mind", and so on.
It's like cult-deprogramming.
Back in the '90s, they
were, you know, doing this,
kidnapping the
person from the cult,
and lockin' 'em up
in a hotel room,
and showing them
videos, or whatever.
It didn't work, 'cause
that's not how it works.
You know, the people...
No one joins a cult,
they joined a group that they
think is a good thing, right?
And then, you know,
months, or years later,
they're down the rabbit-hole,
and they didn't even realize
how extreme they got.
So, it's not gonna
happen overnight.
You just have to
plant a little seed.
Like, "Huh, interesting.
Yeah, I heard that.
I did wonder, though,
I have the..."
I call it the Colombo thing.
"I have just one more question."
(chuckling)
You know, the
detective, Colombo?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Just, "I'm about
to leave, but,
I just thought of one more
thing I was gonna ask you."
And (indistinct)
- You have to wear
a brown trench-coat,
when you're doin' that,
or a tan trench-coat,
turn around and say...
- Right.
- I'm curious, do you have a
certain degree of sympathy,
as you're writing
a book like this,
a certain degree of sympathy
for the people that
fall into these traps?
Because, you know, if you look,
again, if we bring
it back to the news,
if you look at the way
the mainstream media,
for a year said that Brett
Kavanaugh's a serial rapist,
turned out not to be true.
Kyle Rittenhouse is
a white supremacist,
turned out not to be true.
Jussie Smollett was
going to be lynched,
or got attacked
by those two guys,
turned out he hired them.
Donald Trump, "Very fine
people on both sides",
Yes, the sentence
after was, you know,
"I completely condemn
white supremacists".
All of these things
that lead, I think,
a certain set of good
people to, perhaps,
come to wrong conclusions,
but, actually, I'm not even
gonna say that, always.
I think, in some ways,
they then come to
the right conclusion.
But I always say I have sympathy
for the people
that are just like,
"Yeah, these people are
lying to us about so much.
What else do you
expect from us?"
- Yeah, exactly.
So, that's why, you know,
journalism has to stick
to the strict ethic
of fact-checking, and
double-fact-checking,
and multiple sources, and so on,
and they don't do that if it
fits a particular narrative.
Of course we're
we're highlighting
the big stories they got wrong,
most of the stories
they get right
that are not that
big or important,
you know, kind of,
fly under the radar,
and we don't notice those.
Most journalists,
most of the time,
are just doing their job.
It's the big ones
that stand out,
and, in particular,
if it fits a narrative
of your department,
then you probably should
ask for another source.
Or, maybe, let's wait a day.
But, you know, the
economic model, is,
you can't wait a day, right?
We gotta get this out,
before the other
blogger gets it out,
or the other network, right?
So...
Yeah, and again, you know,
you toggle between the three
major networks on the news,
every night, which I do.
It seems like there's a script,
they're all the same stories.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's, like, the same order,
and I'm pretty sure they
don't call each other, go,
"Well, okay, I'm gonna
cover this one, first,
which order are
you gonna put it?"
It's just how the system works.
(chuckling) And
I just, you know,
I wish it was
different or, you know,
there was just more subtlety,
or more, I don't know,
caution, skepticism.
- Michael, can you stick
around for a one more thing,
for my Locals Community?
- Oh yeah, sure.
- 'Cause I wanna,
specifically, ask you about
my favorite conspiracy theory.
We'll do that on Locals,
but the book is
"Conspiracy: Why The Rational
Believe the Irrational"
and we'll link to
it, right down below.
(upbeat electronic intro music)
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about academia,
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our academia playlist.
And, if you wanna
watch full interviews,
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist,
they're all right over here.
And, to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe,
and click the notification bell.